der august ist der monat der
sternschnuppen und wenn er noch ein paar
wünsche frei habt dann schaut unbedingt
an diesem wochenende in den himmel ihr
wisst ja wenn man eine sternschnuppe
sieht dann darf man sich was wünschen
denn jetzt im august erreicht der
perseidenstrom seinen höhepunkten zwar
ist an diesem wochenende denn es wird
wohl bis zu 100 sternschnuppen pro
stunde regnen
das tolle ist sie sind in diesem jahr
besonders gut zu sehen das liegt auch am
mond wann und wo die sternstunden zu
beobachten sind und noch viel mehr jetzt
in klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen vor allem von sonntag auf
montag 12 bis 13 august werden ganze
schwärme am himmel aufblitzen
die perseiden kommen von dem kometen
109p swift tafel der die sonne alle 133
jahre umkreis jährlich nämlich am 12
august kreuzt und seine drecks spur also
der kometenstaub den er im weltall
hinterlässt diese nacht kann man sich
als sterngucker also in jedem jahr dick
im kalender markieren der komet wurde
1862 entdeckt und seine umlaufbahn um
die sonne braucht eben 130 ja mit 252
1000 kilometern pro stunde trinkt sein
kometenstaub in die lufthülle der erde
ein die luft erhitzt sich auf mehr als
3000 grad denn der partikelstrom presst
sie so stark zusammen die perseiden
gehören zu den schnellsten
sternschnuppen überhaupt sternschnuppen
entstehen ja wenn die erde durch diese
trümmerwolke der des kometen fliegt und
die kometen partikel die dann in die
atmosphäre gelangen sind etwa so klein
wie ein stecknadelkopf und dabei
verglühen diese stecknadelköpfe
spektakulär die perseiden sind schon
seit mitte juli unterwegs und werden das
auch noch rund anderthalb wochen seien
nämlich bis zum 24 august von sonntag
auf montag können es bis zu 100
sternschnuppen pro stunde sein und das
ist das absolute traditionelle maximum
in den tagen vorher und nachher flitzen
aber auch immerhin noch bis zu 50
sternschnuppen pro stunde über das
firmament dass der media schauer der
personen besonders gigantisch ist liegt
übrigens daran dass der komet schon so
oft um die sonne gekreist ist dabei hat
er mehr als nur eine spur hinterlassen
und die sorgen dafür diese spuren das
wäre besonders viele sternschnuppen über
so einen langen
zeitraum hinweg beobachten können
fachleute rechnen sogar damit dass auch
einige besonders helle lichtkugeln dabei
sein werden diese boliden können in
ihrer lichtstarke sogar den mond
übertreffen
ja wie auch schon beim blutmond vor zwei
wochen empfiehlt es sich den
sternschnuppen regen an einem möglichst
dunklen ort zu verfolgen also am besten
weit weg von hellen lichtquellen die
beste zeit für die beobachtungen sind
die späten abendstunden und die frühen
morgenstunden das maximum der perseiden
beginnt 2018 am 12 august ab 22 uhr
abends und dauert die ganze nacht ab
etwa halb fünf morgens wird es dann
etwas zu hell sein um sie gut beobachten
zu können super für alle sternschnuppen
fans ist das mondlicht in diesem jahr
denn seine dünne sich die geht schon 21
30 unter wichtig ist dann ein platz mit
freier sicht nach nordost aber insgesamt
solltet ihr den ganzen himmel im blick
haben wenn die perseiden flitzen weit
über den sternenhimmel
manche treten auch erst im südwesten in
die atmosphäre ein falls ihr
fotografieren wollte braucht ihr echt
ein bisschen zeit und geduld er das gut
klappen wird den sternstunden können bis
zu 70 kilometer pro sekunde damit super
schnell sein das sind 252 1000 kilometer
pro stunde
wo auch ja wenn ihr kein video dazu
untereinander dem verpassen wollt dann
hättet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht
denn die etwas unzulässiger boxee auf
youtube und ihr verpasst kein video hat
war hier draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social
and media abonnieren dafür hier klicken
aber nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken kam leben von
kometen auf die erde
bis dann bleibt dran